¿La vieron desaparecer?
Sí, es raro. Tenemos a un tipo. Es del gremio. Trabaja allí arriba todo el día.
Si lo hiciera despacio, si desapareciera inmediatamente,
cae en su bolsillo. Creo que está en este bolsillo.
No, no se fije en su bolsillo. Eso es para otro show.
Entonces... (sonido de chillido), esto es extraño. Existen vacunas para eso.
¿Puedo mostrar qué es? Esto es bastante extraño, ¿Esto es suyo?
No tengo idea de cómo funciona. Pondremos esto por aquí
Perfecto. Necesito ayuda con este.
Venga por aquí, por favor.
No salga corriendo. Ud. tenía algo en el bolsillo de su pantalón.
Estaba revisando mi bolsillo. No pude encontrar todo,
pero noté que tenía algo aquí.
¿Puedo palpar su bolsillo por fuera un momento?
Aquí, noté esto. ¿Esto es suyo, señor?
¿Esto? No tengo idea Es un camarón
Joe: Sí, lo estoy guardando para después.
AR: Ha entretenido a estas personas de forma estupenda
mejor de lo que sabe.
Entonces nos gustaría regalarle este hermoso reloj. (Risas)
Con suerte, será de su gusto.
Pero también tenemos un par de otras cosas.
un poco de dinero, y tenemos algunas otras cosas.
Todo esto le pertenece,
junto con un gran aplauso de todos sus amigos. (Aplausos)
Muchísimas gracias, Joe.
(Aplausos)
Les repito la pregunta que les hice anteriormente,
pero esta vez no es necesario que cierren los ojos.
¿Qué llevo puesto?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
La atención es muy poderosa,
Como dije, le da forma a nuestra realidad.
Creo entonces, que me gustaría formularles esta pregunta.
Si pudieran controlar la atención de alguien,
¿qué harían con ella?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)